OFFICIAL NEW ANCHOR OF "NEW
DAY."
>> IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING ME FEEL SO
WELCOMED, BORIS.
WE BEGIN WITH A DEADLY ROCKET
ATTACK IN UKRAINE.
>> AND DOZENS MORE WERE KILLED
IN ZAPORIZHZHIA LAST NIGHT.
AUTHORITIES ACTUALLY REVISED THE
DEATH TOLL DOWN.
EARLIER THEY SAID 17 HAD BEEN
KILLED.
UKRAINE'S AIR FORCE SAYS THE
CITY WAS HIT BY SIX RUSSIAN
CRUISE MISSILES AND 16
ANTI-AIRCRAFT MISSILES.
>> THE ATTACK COMES A DAY AFTER
THE ONLY BRIDGE AND UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS CELEBRATED THE
EXPLOSION WITHOUT DIRECTLY
CLAIMING SFONT.
LET GET THE LATEST NOW FROM
UKRAINE.
WNN INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
FREDERIK PLEITGEN.
WHAT'S THE LATEST HAPPENING IN
KAPZIA?
>> -- ZAPORIZHZHIA?
AND AS YOU LOOK, CAN YOU SEE
WHY, IT WAS OLD SOVIET
BUILDINGS, A LOT OF PEOPLE,
FAMILIES, LIVE IN THOSE
BUILDINGS.
THESE IMAGES ARE COMING FROM THE
OVERNIGHT HOURS.
YOU COULD SEE SOME OF THE FIRES
AROUND THOSE BUILDINGS.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE SAYING SOME
OF THOSE CRUISE MISSILES WERE
LAUNCHED FROM STRATEGIC BOMBERS.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE
ORDINANCES THAT THE RUSSIANS
FIRED AT THAT CITY.
AT THE SAME TIME, RUSSIANS STILL
TRYING --
[ NO AUDIO ]
>> A DEVASTATING BLOW TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S TO UKRAINE,
STRATEGICALLY AND SYMBOLICALLY.
THE BRIDGE ON FIRE AND HEAVILY
DAMAGED.
MOSCOW'S INVESTIGATING COMMITTEE
AGREEING.
>> Reporter: THE EXPLOSION
CAUSED SEVERAL FIRES AND TWO
LANES PARTIALLY COLLAPSED.
>> THIS VIDEO APPEARS TO SHOW
THE MOMENT OF THE BLAST.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE'S A
MASSIVE EXPLOSION, THOUGH IT'S
NO THE CLEAR WHETHER IT WAS THE
TRUCK THAT ACTUALLY BLEW UP.
RIGGS OFFICIALS SAY SEVERAL WERE
KILLED IN THE ATTACK.
SO FAR NO CLAIM OF
RESPONSIBILITY FROM KYIV'S
LEADERSHIP.
CRIMEA, THE BRIDGE, EVERYTHING
ILLEGAL MUST BE DESTROYED,
EVERYTHING STOLEN MUST BE
RETURNED TO UKRAINE, OCCUPIED BY
RUSSIA MUST BE EXPELLED, AN
ADVISER TO UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT
SAID.
WHILE FOOD TO FUEL SUPPLIES ARIN
SHURD, THIS IS JUST HOURS AFTER
THE BLAST.
THE CRIMEA BRIDGE IS A PRIMARY
SUPPLY ARTERY FOR RUSSIAN FORCES
FIGHTING IN UKRAINE BUT IT'S
ALSO A PRESTIGE PROJECT FOR
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
PUTIN PERSONALLY GROVE A TRUCK
ACROSS THE BRIDGE WHEN IT WAS
OPENED IN 2018.
IT CAME JUST A DAY AFTER PUTIN'S
70th BIRTHDAY.
THIS VIDEO WAS TWEETED
APPARENTLY MOCKING RUSSIA'S
LEADER.
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY,
MR. PRESIDENT ♪
>> UKRAINE'S POSTAL SERVICE WAS
QUICK TO ISSUE A STAFF
COMMEMORATING THE BRIDGE
EXPLOSION.
RESIDENTS TAKING SELFIES IN
FRONT OF THE MAIN POST OFFICE.
>> Reporter: I'VE WAITED FOR THE
MOMENT THAT THE BRIDGE BURNED.
I THINK WE'RE GLAD IT FINALLY
HAPPENED.
>> Reporter: THE DAMAGE TO THE
ROAD SECTION IS MORE EXTENSION,
CREATING ANOTHER BOTTLE NECK FOR
RUSSIAN FORCES IN SOUTHERN
UKRAINE ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
LOGISTICS.
>>> FORCES IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE
ARE SUFFERING LOSSES AND HAVE
BEEN AROUND THE KHERSON AREA.
ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS THEY'VE
BEEN HAVING IS RESUPPLYING THEIR
TROOPS.
CERTAINL